25 years after the UN Convention on the
Rights of the Child came into existence
what are the battles ahead what do MEP s
want to do to improve conditions for
children in Europe we asked Roberta Matt
solar and MEP and lawyer from Malta
who's creating right now a parliamentary
into group on children's rights okay so
our first question comes from UNICEF
let's listen to that sweet Oh total is
born is America your pain a dejar la
como zoo luján awful will you be fair
you have a college let you or soft good
in your pen are they are a convulsion so
vile awful I know what do you answer to
him well the resolution that we are
seeking to adopter this week in plenary
asks also for this that the European
Union exceeds to the UN Convention on
the Rights of the Child we will
obviously have to see the technicalities
of of how this will be done however the
political will is there and I am
confident that at least we can get
agreement between all the political
groups to achieve this aim so now we
asked some children to give their
opinion on what should be next battles
from European Union on children so our
first child jamadar mode is usually a
bazooka lump of FX poker is off up is to
salli ala car door to the mood is that a
problem and you cash absolutely
absolutely because there are still too
many countries not only outside the
European Union where access to education
is not granted to everybody and this is
what we as a European Parliament have
been saying for a long time that our one
of our primary aims is to make sure that
all children have access to at least
basic education we are still very very
far away from that if we if we add other
examples on what should be really your
main priorities or children
butters in the next year's what would
you mention for instance did the crisis
create problems also for minors in
Europe well first of all let's start
from a structural point of view in the
European Parliament we are creating an
intergroup for children's rights
unfortunately there is no committee that
deals with children's rights and we are
a group of members of the European
Parliament's that have decided to pool
our resources together dedicate our time
to see where the problems are and we
have a lot of children that are victims
of violence we have a lot of children
that are victims of racial profiling we
have a lot of children that are because
of the crisis that you mentioned have
fallen outside the priorities of
governments we have to make sure that
which children there is no compromise
politicians have to make sure that they
place policies in favor of access and
inclusion for all children at all levels
in or at least as a priority in their
political plans for the future good
let's listen to the next child case comp
uff Boogedy listen for jiangsu be in
marketers oh yes comp affect who a deal
let's offer jiangsu being get a soft
natural odds are two different things
but first violence we have legislation
that we have adopted against sexual
exploitation child pornography and all
sorts of physical and moral violence
unfortunately not all member states have
implemented that piece of legislation so
we are also calling that first of all
you have to make sure that the basic
rules that you have agreed at on a
political level at the European Union
level that you implement and make sure
the structures in the schools in the
local authorities are well equipped from
counseling point of view also the police
also teachers being trained facilitators
if you have children with a disability
that are more vulnerable than children
that don't have a disability that
everything is in place to protect them
unfortunately we're very far away on the
natural catastrophes yes this is
something that i think the
European Union wakes up always a little
bit too late why because we wait for a
natural catastrophe to happen before we
kick start any crisis mechanism if
children end up without somebody to
protect them then they are very very
vulnerable they are more vulnerable than
adults we have our last question so
let's listen to this living well first
of all what we have said both in Malta
and within the civil liberties committee
in the European Parliament of which I am
a member is that we should never detain
children unfortunately there are
government's who Emma when miners
whether they are accompanied or
unaccompanied arrived at our shores I'm
talking about malta there have been
cases when they have been treated like
adults they have been put in detention
pending a decision being taken on
whether they are eligible or not for
protection what has happened is that
because they are more vulnerable than
adults they have they have sometimes
been found themselves being abused or
discriminated against there is a lot of
legislation that we have accepted we
have adopted everybody says that they
are good pieces of legislation but then
member state governments tend to forget
them what we are saying is miners are
more vulnerable than adults let's give
them the protection they need mercy
thank you very much si vous